тема комп'ютери
то й шукай при страху перед матчами дізнаємось
на невідомо не тим електронної техніки
чим можна ви каре 100 висновок і для
навчання називання цех пристроїв
пізнанні най пушери нижчих то детальні
практичний дізнаємося лінія для ручного
використання стеми прибудуємо і як плану
і цілий кору стол етапі годину на вч вони
демонстрації та початкових чоловіки вас ти
комп'ютері
будуть у праві нас прямо не і тексту в
електронних читалок на прикладі
програм то сайтів для читання
диск ра вибити я чую літератури слухання
музики через навушники
обидва використання вашого вчительського
комп'ютера панель від картин художники
худим важливо рахунок матеріал був
дієві орхідні його вибухи та для
уроки літературного щось не я
українською це англійська йому ви природа
знав що образотворче мистецтво
мозаїчного та інших прагматик солідно ви
чик роботи з електронним текстом на
на перших етапах сторанів 4 дітей прибирати та
виділять і слову обидва рішення для мої
будні спочатку в ікону вати книги
виділеним фрагментом умова
використання простих інтерактивних прав
наприклад access є на екрані
швидко виникає не лише створі
ігрову ситуацію про стимул отрути вирубано
навідник швидко віднімання спеціальні
вправо та застигла ним ефектів анімації
спа лукавити дуже дочка це немає сили ми
словами якщо виявлення ременя володіння
новачкам та користувача комп'ютером у
кожного дуже а в 4 підбираючи ігри тикалі
завдання і кипарис батчаїв після давно ви
у чині функцій тачпада абу мишки та
клавіатури
але я був і кокіль кисть розвиваючих
ігор у дитину чиїх програмах то онлайн
ресурси та key 1 годину на викладати
кілька нормальної функції та розвивали їх
на приклад вже цілих моторів я kenai
найпопулярніший
сир від дітей створення білоруських
програмістів у розділі гелікоптер
гра лічильник після давності написання
шкірні цифри та розум steam розвиваючи
точність руки пальці dt не по тачпаду
про розуміння клавіатурою у v4 плану я
після давно перші чесна принести ви
кори 100 ват та комп'ютер на уроках
математики
природознавство че-то не я то сьогодні
предметах на правила для розвитку в мене
q малювання клавіш ікру вання курсором
за планом вати три ігри і для мене
розвитку навідник цифрової клавіатури
тренажеру знову рахунку гри на
величині таблиці неодноразово отримував
роботу своїх чині алфавітно-цифровий
клавіатурою в унікальна принесено в 4
дітей у міні вати блискавки режими
дано брат і ви лайку літеру ще їду суть
непростим завданням для друга класної до
однієї приватні на тест мене двох клавіш
травня потрійного тесту кілька уроків для
формування такої навички у всіх учень
старший місяць шпалери більше були
залучені увал одиничними елементарними
навички в коростовому ча це незначно покроково
процес у четверо на 5 beard ще ширяє
бача ж по домній величині функції
тачпаду абу мишкою клавіатури надходив
коло за колом 4 травня поїду вати сподівання
новими прибудуємо та
з початковими предметами харчування
організації робочого місця друк роботи
комп'ютера можна майже розкривати її
на перших уроках якщо це говорить
розумом та терміновістю роботи на приклад
планшетом 3 мотання рукою в 15 років
роботи планшет дістати в тому його он з
ручно там і перевагу приставкою
будуть навіть дурні як розміщувати менше
початкової про ладді і до я плив одні
плями брат акули у кабінеті інформатики
дати на прости даяна менше робітники
місця за комп'ютер
титу і не загині раніше після не харчування
з літа було варівати